on a bien un gros problème de dette
privée puisque les entreprises n'ayant
plus de revenus elles sont donc
confrontés à un problème de non
seulement des qualités mais très vite de
solvabilité puisque si si elles n'ont
pas d'activité elles ne peuvent pas
rester comme ça pour toujours en
activité et là effectivement on voit
bien le point délicat de l'action
monétaire c'est que effectivement elle
va traiter de façon relativement
homogène bien évidemment choisissons des
titres mais on va on va dire qu'il va
choisir
par catégories de titres et elle n'aura
elle ne va pas les regarder les
entreprises c'est à dire que dans une
situation comme on a aujourd'hui bien
évidemment des entreprises ont fait
faillite parce qu'il ya des entreprises
plus fragile que d'autres mais dans une
politique de cette mesure on va en fait
assisté l'ensemble des secteurs donc on
va pas aller on va pas discriminer entre
celles qui auraient pu qui aurait dû
faire faillite
parce qu'effectivement de toute façon
elle n'était pas bien géré et donc la
crise est un simplement un révélateur et
celles qui en fait est qu'ils m'ont à
qui on prête et qui vont pouvoir
survivre grâce en fait assez à ces aides
supplémentaires
donc ça c'est en fait la limite de
l'action de la politique monétaire c'est
à dire qu'elle a une portée générale et
elle va pour essayer de maintenir à flot
une économie en termes de valorisation
on va dire mais c'est pas ça qui va
effectivement comme l'a dit précédemment
frédéric si c'est pas ça qui va porter
qui va en fait déboucher vers une
reprise économiques de la reprise
économique elle va venir le jour on va
reprendre de la vraie activité que de
milk qui va générer des produits des
ventes des recettes de l'emploi donc là
la banque centrale elle ne fait que
soutenir des valeurs qui normalement
devraient être moindres puisque on a une
baisse d'activité donc théoriquement la
valeur des entreprises valent moins
lient leur dette va vouloir moins
puisqu'elle ne peuvent pas rembourser
pour le moment les dettes courantes
étant donné qu' il n'y a aucune entrée
en tout cas pour certaines
[Musique]